Speaker 1: OK, this I almost miss this because I
was traveling over the weekend, but my colleague
John told me that there was another one of these
defeat the mandates rallies in Los Angeles over
the weekend. This is one of the most dangerous
dystopian events that I've ever seen. It's also
hilarious in that they bring in speakers that
are like the most boring speakers in the world,
completely uninspiring in any way. And every,
every detail about this event is absolutely
horrifying. We're going to look at some of these
clips. Lara Logan spoke. She's the now Fox host
who has gone completely off the rails. Jimmy
Doray spoke. He's a I can't even really call him
a leftist. He's sort of like a he's kind of like
a neo contrarian, I guess, is what I would say.
He spoke, Robert Malone spoke. Who's this
doctor who's made a lot of headlines by being
skeptical of vaccines and pushing unproven
treatments and this type of thing? And this
is scary in every sense. So let's just look
at a few of these clips, first and foremost.
They brought up a kid to speak a 14 year old kid
whose mannerisms and delivery are very Trumpian.
They brought him up. This might be the most
disturbing moment when they bring up this kid
to speak against vaccines. Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: We are here in Grant Park,
Los Angeles gathered.
Unidentified: Do you want to know why we are
gathered here? Because it's time that our country.
Speaker 1: Free from who? There's no mandates
left. What are you talking about? This
is a freedom activist. Lucky bursary.
Speaker 2: It is time
Unidentified: we stand and fight.
We cannot let the weaklings take us down.
The brainwashed. Well, that defeat us.
Speaker 2: America will be strong again.
And California will be liberated people.
Speaker 1: It's got a kind of mix of the political
ignorance and scientific ignorance we've come to
expect from the anti-vaccine movement, combined
with a kind of. Tent Church revival vibe.
Speaker 2: Our country is in peril, deep peril.
Speaker 1: That's true. But it's in peril because
people are willing to go. More people
are willing to go to a rally like this
rather than to a rally to actually solve
real problems that we have. We are. It is
in peril, but it's because of these people.
Speaker 2: Institution is being disregarded
as nothing more than a piece of paper.
Unidentified: And I will not let it
stand in.
Speaker 2:
This is not a Democratic issue. This is not a
Republican issue, and it's an American issue,
freedom. All Americans deserve
to be free. Our founding fathers.
Speaker 1: This country. All right,
so I am getting a little bit nauseous,
I don't know how much more that we can
do. So that's extraordinarily disturbing.
But then the entire event was was just filled
with some of the most ignorant people that don't
know anything. And it's the blind leading
the blind will look at a couple examples.
Here's one guy who makes some really
strange claims about everything,
including Sweden and.
Speaker 3:
They're going to talk later. They come in
at around three o'clock. But let me end.
Let me end by the critical issue here. This is
about they're coming for our children. There is
no science. There's no data. We've looked at the
science. We looked at the science in Sweden. Zero
deaths, zero. We looked at the science in Germany.
We looked at the data set study that was published
that showed an effect of one infected child who
was exposed to 109 contacts. They followed them.
Not one in of secondary transmission.
Speaker 1: OK, so I don't know what he means
by no one died in Sweden. Like I, I genuinely
don't know what he means if he means no one died
of COVID in Sweden. Obviously, that's not true.
We're putting deaths by age up on the screen.
If he means no children died of COVID in Sweden,
I mean, that's also not true. What Sweden is has a
much smaller Sweden's like a U.S. state, right?
I mean, it is a relatively small population.
15 kids, nine and younger died of COVID
in Sweden, eight kids 10 to 90. I mean,
I don't know what he means, but obviously
people died in Sweden, so that was weird.
Then this was interesting. Jimmy Doré spoke, and
he's reading off of a piece of paper, everybody,
including Jimmy. He doesn't even seem to know
what he's reading, and it's just all so weird.
Speaker 4: Things and passports are the
major issue of the day, with millions of
people protesting against them worldwide. In
fact, what has become known as the medical
freedom movement is arguably the biggest and most
diverse international movement in world history.
Speaker 1: Really an inspiring speaker, huh?
Speaker 4: And you're part of it, know vaccine
mandates. Vaccine passports are among the most
vile, unconstitutional, immoral, unscientific,
discriminatory and outright criminal
policies ever enforced upon this population.
That's the Black Caucus or the
Green Party. The white supremacists
don't turn on each other. I have more in common
with every person here than I do with Bill Gates.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And I guess what he means is
like even though he's ostensibly on the left
and this is like a mostly right wing nut tree
rally, he has more in common with them. I mean,
like, yeah, we know that. That seems pretty
clear. Another great inspirational speaker,
it's hard not to hear Dr. Robert Malone speak
and just feel energy coursing through you with
Speaker 4: dignity and community integrity is a
commitment to truth in what you say, how you live
and how you treat others dignity and close respect
for ourselves, for each other and for the world we
live in. Community is what binds us together is
what's gone wrong is what binds us together to
each other and gives our lives purpose and meaning
Speaker 1: an absolutely electric. Dr. Robert
Malone reading off of a laptop.
Speaker 4: These are the three
things we must recover if we will heal.
The problem is not a virus. The problem
is the damage that has been done to
us as human beings and as a community.
On the other day when they enjoyed by other
churches and Jerry Sandusky. The doctor, the
Roman Catholic Church, who famously said the truth
is like a lion, you, you don't have to defend it,
let loose, it will defend itself.
Speaker 1: Naomi Wolf was there.
She's also sort of like someone formerly, I
guess, associated with the left who's gone
completely out of her mind. She appears
to have almost like a psychotic event
or some kind of mania. Check this out.
Speaker 2: There are a lot of moms out here
in dads, but I want to speak as a mom and as
a stepmom. You hurt our kids and watch out.
Unidentified: Because you have never faced
downgrades of thousands of furious Mother Earth.
And it's like,
Speaker 1: what are you guys protesting against?
I don't even really understand what, what, why the
event is happening. They then interviewed a Dr.
Michael Wang who claims he's treated 3000 COVID
patients, and he uses this bizarre phrase where
he says he has helped a thousand kids come off
of masks almost like some kind of drug treatment
program. It's a bizarre 60 seconds of video.
Speaker 4: There are some cities that are still
holding on to mask mandates, even for toddlers.
What would you say to parents that are wanting
to believe? Maybe your message? What would you say
the physician's view is of children wearing masks?
We have help over a thousand kids
come off mask. I cheated. What does
Speaker 1: that mean? We've thus they brought
them in and we detox them. And it was tough. We
gave them the we gave and we got them off of the
masks. It was tough. They were sweating. They had
the cold sweats, but we got them off of the masks.
Speaker 4: You children with COVID website never
had to actively prescribe any medication. There's
a tremendous stratification between the young
and the old slate of young people, basically
very, very mild disease. So no fear. I need
to let the parents know. Do not be afraid.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, you know, again,
most people recover and most people
recover without taking anything,
but they cite that like that should really change
our perspective. Most people don't die of COVID.
Most people don't die of COVID. Most people don't
need any medication to recover. But that doesn't
make a plan for dealing with a pandemic.
Is it not not surprising? And then lastly.
There was anti-trans stuff at the
defeat, the mandate's rally as well.
You tell me what the connection
is between anti-trans and anti
mass anti-mask and anti-vaccine in the dark
Speaker 2: you eat when you're hungry away.
I've got one for you. I don't
know if you're ready for this,
right? Men are not women.
Unidentified:
Wait a minute,
Speaker 1: wait a minute. What a powerful message
for medical freedom there, so an extraordinarily
dangerous event. And again, the really the really
scary and horrible thing is. That people go to
this stuff. These things, these movements have
followers in the United States. And it is
really scary because we all want to solve real
problems. And when you've got a not insignificant
portion of the population buying into this stuff,
what what a and really a tragic event. Everyone
who is there should be absolutely humiliated